ma tornando il vero di hera microfono
grazie a mia madre 72 ore prima
ma davvero alla sua amministrazione
termini sono con gianmarco la linea
enrico errico
eccolo stiamo andando a sanremo ragazzi
stiamo partendo al tuo tempo ci vuole
sette ore 46 romantico guarda fuori dal
finestrino e fingiti pensieroso esatto
pensierosa
siamo un treno gams ora e mezza ma la
vostra
abbiamo lavorato per quattro ore e mezza
adesso stiamo impazzendo ci stiamo
uccidendo di si può anche perché
arriveremo pronti ma sarà tantissimo
quindi almeno quei problemi con
l'albergo vediamo è stata praticamente
per il william dovevamo andare avanti
quindi dalle urne rapallo è rimasto nel
nostro cuore a ragazzi che bella rapallo
qua dietro abbiamo un concorrente di
sanremo ragazzi abbiamo la completamente
innanzitutto il disabile e pepe sembra
molto carino il bagno ragazzi richiede
sempre delle performance canore anche se
di dubbio gusto per la martella
siamo pronti per andare all'hotel
principe
a londra ci saranno vari tifare era
d'italia e oggi incominceremo a fare i
primi incontri chiacchiere con tutti
quanti mar i concorrenti non era più
carico farlo è stato affascinato per
azione
io prendo il commento della linea e
andiamo avanti stavo camminando da due
ore 6 buglio 6 anche il mio umore dove
alla fine aver scoperto quello che
dovevamo andare non era quello che
pensavamo ma uno che stava 22 minuti a
piedi per cui adesso tipo giovani
marmotte stiamo camminando la linea coi
tacchi corazza mani come stai
storica e ragazze è successo di nuovo
oggi sono lidiana sei pronto per
l'intervista c'è il fratello
ciao ragazzi sono guglielmo insieme a
vanity fair era italia ci troviamo a
sanremo adesso stiamo qui in compagnia
di francesco gabanizza un lievo ciao a
tutti noi vorremmo farti prendere
demented are avremo un giochino insieme
ok abbiamo selezionati vari ma per tempo
cioè slam una domanda a bruciapelo
dovrei rispondere nel minor tempo
possibile e serafino schiacciarmi fatte
data quindi evo premere alla fine ha
risposto quindi faremo un tuo amico di
vita a cena cosa porta in sé stesso per
voi è uscito sannino mi metterò delle
carte sulla testa a questa categoria
personaggi famosi e dovrete i marlins a
parlare per farmi di capire e papà
stiamo giocando a sanremo dovrà mettere
le cuffie di scaleremo della musica e
dovrei capire delle frasi in chetino di
voi qui kiwi quindi le risposte certo
meritato lo metterò dietro alle piana
perché mediana come quella preferita
lo vendette apre col sorcio in bocca è
vicino al buffet è un caso per andare a
lavorare me la guardo il gip dall'altro
lato
qual è stata la tua prima celebrity
crush on
stai ti siedi su una mandorla
ma cosa è successo in passato buona
parte preferita in una donna e il collo
ok dirigere si dice lorca coerenza il
maestro in mezzo mette beppe vessicchio
beppe vessicchio di meter cose che se
fai sole carmine gomito e sopra la
racconta hryo e da piccolo come fame una
sincera dirige l'orchestra e dirige
l'orchestra il maestro maestro beppe
vessicchio di massima con la quale luca
bucci a chi ha detto la parte preferita
della donna sì esatto maestro il viaggio
maestro maestro un bacio beppe babette
vessicchio è un peccato euro gomorra
bombolo
pur blu ma se non riesce a terminare il
bel mezzo della notte cosa fai mi
sveglio il modo con me
godo come un riccio quale linea più
imbarazzanti con cui si è fatto chiamare
e crociati saluta pippo baudo una rambla
baudo tanto chiaramente tanto tanto cara
chiaramente non sono ancora c'è un
precog e leggi nel pensiero se
bravissimo apparato c'è la musica
pippo baudo pippo baudo
se dico tu la prima del pezzo e pippo
baudo davvero stop al televoto dopo
avviene con la tua parolaccia preferita
ma ma tra fan grazie invece alla mente i
doriani ma non è vinto ne vanta pure noi
siamo assolutamente ci si mette più
tempo non so quanti 6 perché ho detto
cose caffè 45
ma cosa vuoi che certo non sta facendo
niente è un amico ma al quale ho chiesto
gentilmente di massaggiarmi il mio caso
servirà a pensar male mandato un
messaggio è molto bella
perché io quando questo della coppia mi
sento proprio a casa e quindi come di
fare una vacanza per quello www dobbiamo
avanti no no io d'onda cantavo
sì devo andare a cantare all'ariston
scusa lo scopo
per andare a cantare la figlia lo sai
corrompendo ma mettiamo è il cibo che
trova a me non sono io che ero cieli
hostel e denutrito allora signori adesso
ho il piacere di presentarvi un ospite
speciale canterà a sanremo ed è fuori
gara perché viene direttamente dall
american pie bol ecco cosa poi tuoi
stessi e domani domani è il compleanno è
il compleanno di gialli
già mi vedo tre volte posso avere
qualcuno di più capace a volte bisogna
accettarsi a volte e mangio senza
lattosio
l'elettore a bra suicidio ma la
matriciana se aggiungi sergio
castellitto
alla fine alla fine mangiar sano mangio
sano e capisci sono le cose del cibo e
la pasta al pomodoro la pappa al
pomodoro è buona ma è buona se ci
aggiungi i parmigiani
se ci aggiunge il parmigiano madonna
napoleone ha governato dalla francia la
mongolfiera non lavora apollo pollo
pollo fritto pollo fresco sushi sushi
marmitta parmigiano ormai mi fare lo
sforzo di queste favoriti totti senza
lattosio o anche per noi intollerante
banchetti lamine adesso veramente non
sono mai
e durata solo tenete lo giuro per una
ragazza vediamo subito di tre sabati
mattina early ormai non si può più fare
niente che c'è l'occhio di sauron anno e
4.000 avrebbe detto sempre il solito
massaggio tecnica più mentre giapponese
leggera l'angioletto canzoni che non
potete cantare perché non si può cantare
ma che dovete riuscire a farmi capire mi
ma mica un anno dall abbiamo sono sempre
stato scarsissimo questa categoria
azioni di uno abbia un pannolino a
mettere in mente il palloncino cambiarlo
cambiasso non ce l'ho genova
no amore mio
dirige l'orchestra che canta il maestro
è pazzo se diamo anticipo a 66 cinta e
cartoline
aspetta aspetta che sta arrivando una
cosa più importante che questo le prime
due preside formato fascino rimane ben
una divisa mi aveva solo per la via con
la porchetta si può mangiare né possono
assaggiare i ragazzi questo è mia queste
mie acque del rio e anche quelli che
devono arrivare si stabilirà con vani
che non so se l'ho già spiegato come sta
facendo dell'intervista tutti quanti
grazie mille
però si trasforma ne manca uno quindi
stiamo incontrando artisti non solo che
al contrario degli altri realtà invece
che di domande sul festival di sanremo e
stiamo facendo giocare e quindi quello
che vedete adesso il buzzer la cuffia
campo i cartellini sono in realtà di ciò
che stava facendo con loro qual è la
cosa più dei ribelli che fatto con degli
utili già rubato un mazzo di chiavi di
una marcia ma chi te l'ha fatto fare ai
capi tanto sai con la chiesa tra stasera
tutte le idee mi il noi è un personaggio
famoso e dove tra di quella telepatia
io glielo faccio indovinare c'è solo un
problema che ti soffre lo stesso gioco
mio fratello per festa chiedo di un film
ma con una lettera cambiata è la storia
di un reduce del vietnam forma
geometrica però è la soglia dell'uomo di
un uomo che non è a forma di stella
mafai cocktail bar man a barre mancate
aspetta spetta al governo ha reso edotto
ha preso un duro perché sto molto bravo
poliziotto cibernetico ma con una
deformazione della nascita dopo co
celo celo celo celo praticamente una
storia d'amore bellissima ha commosso
lee sale mondiali
una nave che a un certo punto non riesce
ad arrivare alla fine del viaggio per
colpa di un egemone crudele pirani che
mamma mia
nell'intervista queste è andata ragazzi
ha visto solamente facendo il cielo di
un altro che dico è la storia di una
candida imbarcazione che per colpa di un
frutto smette di navigare a sorpresa più
tardi passato è stato più difficile
perché ho capito che eri un passo avanti
quindi con mette in difficoltà bianca
nave senti questo qua ti sei in campo di
concentramento alla radio danno jacques
brel e pensare di essere in germania
invece la vita è bella e sapevo che
bella ma non riuscivo a capirlo siamo
sempre in un campo di concentramento
storia drammatica bianco e nero se fosse
per uno sprazzo di colore e stiamo
parlando diciamo di un'ultima quindi a
ucciderla
morgan è stato bellissimo a quello che
avete appena visto è due minuti dari
alternativi con cube morgan che altro
dire prego
[Musica]
le persone mascherate fatto una pausa ma
un altro erano mascherati che per quelle
personali è uno che va in una
partnership non c'è differenza per
quello che riguarda io quello all'isola
di sterrato lo posso vedere fuori
criminale bloccare commentate metti tu
un pollice in su iscriviti al canale di
tutti siamo dati la ristampa mini che
siamo primi figli 63 davanti all'ariston
tesori la ripresa
comprava la sorpresa gianmarco del sé
compleanno non ci siamo riusciti
vogliamo continua ad invitarmi una busta
sono quattro restano i miei cugini sono
pazzeschi
gianmarco i suoi non si salva apprezzo
il gesto rotte mai vista tanta tanti
auguri a te tanti auguri a tanti auguri
faccio tanti auguri a nonno jam accolta
scavalcato come non abbiamo coltello
cosi gianni ma aspetta non ci sembro più
me meglio
meglio quindi è meglio il cartone su
carlo anche tu ma anche perché me la
fine mi mandi tutta infilare il dito qui
sotto
alzare e al bar musica del primo set ha
detto lingua come mai sono grido in mano
pulitissimo non sentite il bagna tiziano
registico no no l'art 3 della serie in
festeggiato la grande regalo per il
festeggiato ora più mi sono piazzato i
capelli
quindi se non la mangi in un video la
dovrei mangiare così 99
nessuna votazione ragazzi è più utile
del ferro da stiro con gli altri
beh nel momento in cui non c'è un ferro
da stiro sicuro così sono stanco di
vedere persone che piange ma una cosa mi
piace tuo fratello e l'umidità e la
modestia e comunque da vi prego non
averti permesso di avere un sogno
[Applauso]
è un avendo a bordo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
perché non è stata colpa tua e la
ringrazio ma comunque l'ha eseguita
braci insegnanti sportivi titani appena
pc di rispondere così ti faccio quella
dopo perché come la funzione un
programma più fatta allora abbiamo poco
tempo
allora abbiamo poco tempo ora si parla
si dice con la cassa il pazzo beppe
vessicchio fatti un festino è esatto
qual è la cosa più ribelle che fatto con
degli unti leggera spogliarmi piazza del
duomo a firenze ma lei doppiato ma dimmi
tre cose che teneva il comodino un
saluto un saluto a tutti i
telespettatori e offerta c'è la
pubblicità va a tutti i telespettatori
si dice lui non era non entra il maestro
il fasto beppe beppe vessicchio
assomiglio piovono parole profugo parole
dopo no microfono io con microfono
parole parole su questa città su questa
città quindi lavano parole su questa
città qual è la tua parolaccia preferita
semmai capiterà ci faccio una partita
qualcosa di sensato i seal abbiamo
scoperto consacrazione anche a chi non
conoscono quindi l'idea di la miniera
prendere arrivo gianmarco metteri da sua
pelliccia quegli occhiali neri e poi
mentre scende le scale che con delle
persone di fano a todi card abbiamo
delle comparse quelle ragazze che sono
loro che devo iniziare urlare dollari
andrà e monti amiamo galleria un
esperimento sociale era contro altre
persone chiederanno da poco al dorati
coinvolte grazie dovrai
bravissimo numerosi e la microfono
grazie mille
posso dire che hai un ottimo gusto 9
hanno già tagliato la mia avventura
all'interno del festival di sanremo
finisce qui è stata una settimana molto
molto speciale ringrazio a tutti gli
artisti che sono venuti qua io vi
ricordo che se volete vedere tutti
quelli che sono stati i contenuti che
abbiamo girato potete andare su youtube
su instagram di vanity fair pò su
www.vanityfair.it ringrazio ancora
vanity fair
diciamo un'altra volta radio italia ma
soprattutto elettra borghini per avermi
definito un bono ciao e chissà alla
prossima nel prossimo episodio è un po
soffitta di yogurt